>>> SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
YOUR FAVORITE PRODUCTS SHRINKING
IN PORTION SIZE, A GROWING TREND
THAT ECONOMISTS CALL
SHRINKFLATION WHICH IS A THING.
WITH US NOW, ALISON KOSIK, IT IS
NOT A WELCOME THING.
>> I SPOKE WITH THE AUTHORITY ON
THIS SUBJECT, A SUPPLY CHAIN
PROFESSOR AT ARIZONA STATE
UNIVERSITY.
HE SAYS SHRINKFLATION IS
SOMETHING THAT COMPANIES DON'T
WANT YOU TO NOTICE AND IT IS
BASED ON ONE BASIC TENET, THAT
EVERY COMPANY LIVED BY, THEY'RE
IN THE BUSINESS NOT JUST TO MAKE
MONEY, BUT TO MAKE MORE MONEY.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS
MANUFACTURERS QUIETLY SHRINKING
THE SIZE OR AMOUNT IN THE
PRODUCT BUT NOT LOWERING THE
PRICE.
THEY'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FACING HIGHER COSTS LIKE
PRODUCTION COSTS.
AND LABOR COSTS.
THEY HAVE GOT ONE CHOICE HERE OF
THREE, THEY COULD EAT THE COST
AND REDUCE THEIR PROFIT AND
SHIELD THE CONSUMER, BUT DON'T
LAUGH BECAUSE THEY WOULD NEVER
DO THAT.
THEY COULD PASS ON THE EXTRA
COST TO THE CONSUMER, BUT RUN
THE RISK OF THE CONSUMER GOING
TO A DIFFERENT PRODUCT SO WE GO
TO DOOR NUMBER THREE,
SHRINKFLATION, THEY LESSEN THE
AMOUNT OF THINGS INSIDE THE
PACKAGE OR SHRINK THE SIZE AND
DON'T LOWER THE PRICE.
WHERE ARE WE SEEING THIS?
WE FOUND SOME PRODUCTS, YOU SEE
THE CHARMIN HERE, IF YOU LOOK
CLOSELY, YOU'LL SEE THE SIZE OF
THE ROLLS WENT FROM 396 SHEETS
TO 366 SHEETS.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW IT, IT SAYS
SUPER MEGA ON TOP.
SPARKLE PAPER TOWELS, THEY
LOPPED OFF SIX SEHEETS FROM EVEY
ROLL, GOING FROM 116 TO 110.
DAWN DISH WASHING LIQUID, 6
OUNCES FOR THE SMALLEST SIZE,
BOTH BOTTLES SCANNED AT $1.79 AT
CVS IN MAY.
THE PRICE DID NOT GO DOWN ON
THAT ONE.
AND HERE IS MY FAVORITE,
GATORADE, IT GREW A WAISTLINE
HERE, IT USED TO BE 32 OUNCES IT
NOW 28 OUNCES, BUT IT IS THE
SAME HEIGHT, YOU SEE IT THERE.
I DID CONTACT ALL THE
MANUFACTURERS FOR THESE PRODUCTS
AND THEY DIDN'T GET BACK TO ME
EXCEPT FOR PEPSICO, THE MAKER OF
GATORADE.
THEY SAID THE 28 OUNCE BOTTLE
YOU SEE HERE IS NOT NEW, THE
32-OUNCE BOTTLE IS BEING PHASED
OUT AND THE REASON FOR THE NEW
SHAPE IS YOU CAN HOLD IT BETTER,
BUT THEY SAY THAT IT IS NOT
BECAUSE THERE IS THE NEW -- THE
NEW SHAPE IS NOT BECAUSE OF ANY
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS GOING ON.
JOHN AND KAITLAN.
>> SLIMMING CONTAINER THERE ON
THE GATORADE.
ALL RIGHT, YOU THINK IT IS
HAPPENING, IT REALLY IS.
APPRECIATE IT.
>> YOUR MIND IS NOT PLAYING
TRI
TRICKS ON YOU.
>> MAYBE, BUT NOT IN THIS CASE.
>>> THIS MORNING, PRESSURE AT
THE PUMP IS EASING FOR MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS AS GAS PRICES HAVE
NOW FALLEN FOR THE 35th STRAIGHT
DAY.
THE NATIONWIDE AVERAGE NOW SITS
AT $4.50 PER GALLON.
THAT IS GOING TO MAKE MY DAD
VERY HAPPY.
THIS AFTER THE COST OF A GALLON
WAS CLOSE TO $5 LAST MONTH.
CNN'S PETE MUNTEAN IS LIVE IN
ALEXANDRIA, VIRGINIA, WHERE HE
ALWAYS IS, EXCEPT WHEN HE'S AT
THE AIRPORT.
PETE, ARE YOU SEEING SOME HAPPY
CUSTOMERS SHOWING UP THIS
MORNING?
>> 17 STATES, KAITLAN, HAVE SEEN
THEIR GAS PRICES DROP 50 CENTS
IN THE LAST WEEK.
VIRGINIA IS ONE OF THEM.
$4.69 HERE AT OUR STATION THAT
WE ALWAYS GO TO IN ALEXANDRIA.
THAT IS ABOVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE, WHICH IS NOW $4.50
ACCORDING TO AAA.
DROPPED TWO CENTS OVERNIGHT.
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT WE
WERE HERE TALKING, WONDERING
WHEN GAS PRICES WOULD GO ABOVE
$4.50.
LET'S THINK BACK TO WHERE WE
WERE A MONTH AGO.
GAS PRICES WERE $4.98 ON
AVERAGE.
THEY REALLY PEAKED ON JUNE 14th,
$5.02.
THE MOST COMMON PRICE IN THE
U.S. RIGHT NOW, ACCORDING TO GAS
BUDDY, YOU'LL SEE THIS A LOT,
$3.99.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
THE REASONS THE PRICE OF OIL IS
DROPPING BECAUSE THERE ARE THESE
FEARS ABOUT A GLOBAL RECESSION,
AND THAT COULD POSSIBLY CRATER
DEMAND FOR GAS.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO DRIVERS
NOW, WHO REALIZE BIG PICTURE,
THIS BAD ECONOMIC NEWS MAY BE A
BIT OF GOOD NEWS IN THE
SHORT-TERM FOR THEM.
>> RIGHT NOW IT IS RIDICULOUS AT
THIS TIME OF MOMENT.
MY HUSBAND BEING A TRUCK DRIVER,
SO RIGHT NOW HE'S PAYING, LIKE,
$600, $700 A GALLON, YOU KNOW,
TRAVELING BACK AND FORTH.
>> I'M GLAD THE GAS WENT DOWN.
IT IS MAKING PEOPLE FEEL A WHOLE
LOT BETTER.
>> HOW MUCH LOWER DO YOU WANT IT
TO GO?
>> I WOULD SAY PROBABLY IN THE
$2 RANGE.
ABOUT $2.50, $2.75, I THINK
PEOPLE WOULD BE SATISFIED.
>> Reporter: OKAY, $2.50 AND
$2.75, PRETTY UNLIKELY.
A YEAR GO WE SAW GAS AT $3.17
FOR A GALLON OF REGULAR ON
AVERAGE, THOUGH PATRICK DUHAN OF
GAS BUDDY SAYS WE COULD SEE GAS
SLIP BY ANOTHER DIME, $3.49 ON
AVERAGE, BY THE END OF THIS
WEEK.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TRYING
TO TAKE A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
THIS.
THEY TAPPED THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE, THEY PUT MORE
PRESSURE ON OIL COMPANIES, ONE
OF THE TOP ECONOMICE ADVISERS
SAID $4 IS GOOD, BUT NOT GOOD
ENOUGH.
WE'LL SEE IT GO DOWN MORE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION GETS ITS WAY.
>> YOU CANNOT OVERSTATE HOW MUCH
THE WHITE HOUSE IS WATCHING THE
NUMBERS, THEY CHECK THEM EVERY
SINGLE DAY, MULTIPLE TIMES A
DAY.
PETE MUNTEAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.